Nos dicen que: "Tomás tiene una estantería. La
siguiente tabla muestra cuántos libros hay en
cada estante. El 1er estante tiene 19 libros,
el 2° estante tiene 24 libros, el 3er estante
tiene 32 libros y el 4° estante tiene 7 libros.
¿Cuántos libros hay en total en la estantería?"
Así que pausa este video y ve si puedes
resolverlo antes de que lo analicemos juntos.
Muy bien, ahora trabajemos juntos. Entonces, si
queremos saber cuántos libros hay en total en
la estantería, esencialmente tenemos que sumar
19 libros a 24 libros a 32 libros a 7 libros,
así que realmente esto será 19 + 24 + 32 + 7,
eso es lo que realmente tenemos que resolver.
Ahora, ¿cómo podemos hacerlo? Bueno, me gusta
comenzar separando las decenas de las unidades,
por ejemplo, podría reescribir 19 como 10 + 9:
tengo una decena y nueve unidades, una decena y
nueve unidades; podría reescribir 24 como 20 + 4;
y podría reescribir 32 como 30 + 2, y por último,
pero no menos importante, podría reescribir 7,
bueno en realidad no tengo que reescribir 7 ya
que 7 sólo tiene siete unidades, así que escribo
7 justo aquí. Y ahora lo que puedo hacer es tomar
cada uno de estos que viene de las decenas, así
que tendría 10 + 20 -sólo lo estoy tachando para
poder llevar un seguimiento- más 30, así que tomé
estos tres; y luego tomo todos los dígitos que
tengo en la posición de las unidades: sumamos 9 +
4 + 2 + 7. Ahora, ¿cuánto es 10 + 20 + 30? 10 + 20
es 30 y luego más 30 será 60. Otra forma de
pensar en esto es que tengo una decena más otras
dos decenas, lo que me da tres decenas, más otras
tres decenas, lo que me da seis decenas, así que
eso es 60. ¿Y cómo resolvemos esta parte? Bueno,
puedo hacer esto en cualquier orden, puedo ver que
2 + 7 = 9, 9 + 9 = 18, por lo que esto es lo mismo
que 18 + 4, y luego vemos que se necesita 2 para
llegar a 20, y luego tengo otros dos -permíteme
escribirlo de esta manera-. Puedo escribir esto
como 60 más, y si sólo tomo 2 de 4 y lo pongo en
el 18 será 20 + 2: esto y esto son equivalentes. Y
la razón por la que hice eso es que ahora es fácil
sumar 20 a 60: estas son dos decenas más seis
decenas, lo que nos da ocho decenas, esto es 80; y
luego 80 + 2 es, por supuesto -redoble de tambor-,
la respuesta es 82, esa es la cantidad total
de libros que Tomás tiene en su estantería.